eso bien que es una ciudad que es
atacada constantemente esta calle que
está a mis espaldas todas las
edificaciones tienen la fachada dañada y
este edificio el ladrillo en un colegio
parece no es el único ataque ayer se
daba un ataque aéreo desde un avión uno
de los pocos que se han dado en la zona
del donbass donde los ataques suelen ser
con misiles y con artillería y es que en
la batalla se reactiva en esta zona y se
cree que las tropas rusas están
reagrupando para atacar esta ciudad que
después de cra motors sería la más
importante por esta zona de el donbass
sin embargo es interesante porque si en
mayo gran parte de la población se había
marchado un gran número regresó porque
pensaban que las condiciones eran
mejores o porque no tenían dinero para
vivir como desplazados en otras partes
de ucrania o en otros países a los que
habían emigrado sin embargo las
autoridades han prendido las alarmas
porque no solamente la guerra se acerca
sino que las condiciones de vida son muy
difíciles las personas tienen que venir
a lugares como esos hasta y sacar agua
porque no hay en la ciudad tampoco hay
gas lo que hace que muchos tengan que
cocinar con leña en los jardines